while attorneys say the school district
failed to protect one of its students
from anti-semitic attack now are award
is being offered for any information
that leads to a conviction eight news
now education reporter Joshua piguero
digs into the allegations of this at a
Las Vegas school
there are several questions about what
happened on March 9th once a teenager
left Clark High School and walked home a
swastika which is the Nazi hate symbol
was carved into this child's back and
clearly this is an anti-semitic hate
crime the victim a 17 year old who wore
a yamaka is autistic and non-verbal his
attorney Brooke Goldstein says he had a
shadow assigned to guide him around
Clark High School in a statement
regarding this incident CCSD says quote
police conducted a thorough
investigation including interviews with
staff and a review of available camera
footage the investigation found no
evidence that would indicate the origin
of the injuries Goldstein disputes those
findings and says the fact the
perpetrator is still out there is
traumatizing so far to date the
investigations have
um you know at the very least Fallen
incredibly sure short of what should
happen Sam hodari saw the photos and
inspired him to offer a five thousand
dollar reward that's disgusting and
disturbing and the kid that cannot talk
and communicate and went through such a
horrific situation data from the
Anti-Defamation League shows in Nevada
last year there were 30 reported
incidents of anti-Semitic attacks down
from the previous year but Jolie brislin
with the ADL says it's still concerning
when we see a rise of anti-Semitism
taking place we see a rise of racism of
anti-immigrants of anti-asian anti-lgbt
hate the district adds in a statement
that it won't tolerate any Behavior
that's contradictory to the inclusive
community it strives to build reporting
outside Clark High School Joshua progero
8 News Now
and the Anti-Defamation League also says
it's currently working with Clark High
School and the district to provide
anti-Semitism and anti-bias education